حسنًا ، كان هذا هو الانخفاض الذي رأيناه في وقت مبكر من
صباح يوم الاثنين ، حيث وصل الجنيه البريطاني إلى
دولار واحد وثلاثة سنتات وهو
مستوى لم نشهده منذ عام 1985. أقل
من يوم الأربعاء الأسود الذي لدينا
هنا في عام 1992 عندما انهار الجنيه الإسترليني
أو  2008 الأزمة المالية
أو بالطبع التصويت على خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي
في الآونة الأخيرة في عام 2016. قوة الدولار الأمريكي
هي جانب آخر من هذه القصة ولكن
تحركات الجنيه الاسترليني مقارنة
بالعملات الأخرى مهمة حقًا الآن حيث
انخفض الجنيه ، وكانت القصة المعاكسة
للديون الحكومية  هنا لدينا
سندات المملكة المتحدة لمدة 10 سنوات ، لذا فإن ما نراه
هنا هو زيادة هائلة في تكلفة
الاقتراض للحكومة في الواقع
العائد على 10 سنوات فوق أربعة بالمائة
يوم الاثنين وهو أعلى مستوى
لدينا  لقد رأينا منذ أكثر من عقد سبب
انهيار هذا السوق جيدًا هنا ، فلدينا
رئيس وزراء
جديد ، فلنثق في حكومة المملكة المتحدة الجديدة ،
وهذا عندما كشفت عن
خطتها للإنفاق الكبير في نهاية الأسبوع الماضي ، فإنها
تريد تنفيذ تخفيضات ضريبية كبيرة
سيكلف الأمر 45 مليار
جنيه من الآن وحتى أه 2027. وأيضًا على
الرغم من أنه يريد إنفاق الكثير من المال
لمحاولة دعم فواتير الطاقة الشعبية ،
فهذا بالنسبة للأسر والشركات
يعتقد أنه سيكلف 60 مليار
جنيه وهذا في الواقع فقط في  الأشهر المقبلة ،
لذا سيضطرون إلى
اقتراض الكثير من المال الآن هنا باللون الأزرق ،
يمكنك أن ترى ما كان متوقعًا بالنسبة
لاقتراض حكومة المملكة المتحدة الذي كان
قبل هذه الخطة هنا باللون الأحمر ، يمكنك أن ترى
أين يمكن أن تذهب هذا تقدير
من هيئة الأبحاث الاقتصادية
ومعهد الدراسات المالية وسيتي بنك
ويمكنك أن ترى في هذه السنة المالية
أنه يتوقع أن يتضاعف الاقتراض تقريبًا
وفي العام المقبل أكثر من
الضعف ، لذا فإن هذا يمثل الكثير من الأموال التي
تحتاجها الحكومة من المستثمرين الأجانب
لإقراضها المال و  بالطبع ، في الوقت
الحالي ، يتجنبون الأصول في المملكة المتحدة ، لذا
فهم بحاجة إلى مزيد من الثقة ،
لذا كان
يتوقع بعض الاقتصاديين أن
يتخذ بنك إنجلترا يوم الاثنين نوعًا من الإجراءات الفورية  ربما
يكون رفع سعر الفائدة طارئًا على الرغم من رفع
أسعار الفائدة الأسبوع الماضي فقط بمقدار نصف
نقطة مئوية وهو في الواقع
الارتفاع السابع على التوالي الذي حصلنا عليه الآن
من بنك إنجلترا بدلاً من ذلك ، هذا في
الواقع ما حصلت عليه الأسواق
من بيان من البنك المركزي يقول
كانوا يراقبون التطورات وكان
لديهم هذه التغريدة من
محافظ بنك إنجلترا قائلاً إنهم لن
يترددوا في تغيير الأسعار حسب الحاجة
لإعادة التضخم إلى 2 في المائة من الخط
الذي سمعناه عدة مرات من قبل ، لذا
فالأمر متروك للمستثمرين أم لا  كانوا
يشعرون أن هذا كان كافيا لتعزيز
ثقتهم في المملكة المتحدة آنا ستيوارت سي إن إن
لندن
الأجنبية